[Musik]
herzlich willkommen schön dass Sie dabei
sind an diesem Sonntag Mittag vor zwei
Jahren im Herbst da stand die SPD vor
einer fast unlösbaren Aufgabe sie wollte
eine Koalition bilden mit zwei Partnern
die finanzpolitisch das genaue Gegenteil
voneinander im Wahlkampf versprochen
hatten die FDP stand zur Schuldenbremse
wollte Steuern auf keinen Fall erhöhen
und die Grünen hatten ihrer Wählerschaft
viel Geld versprochen für Investitionen
in Klimaschutz und Veränderung der
Wirtschaft da hatte jemand eine Idee
damals noch Finanzminister Olaf Scholz
kam auf den Gedanken einfach altes Geld
zu nehmen dass die merkelreierung sich
hatte genehmigen lassen für coronahilfen
neues Etikett und schwups waren 60
Milliarden für grüne Projekte da das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat einen
dicken fetten Strich durch diese
Rechnung gemacht diese Woche zum ersten
Mal in der bundesdeutschen Geschichte
ist ein Haushaltsgesetz
verfassungswidrig und in der ampelkasse
klafft ein großes Loch unser Thema heute
Urteil mit Sprengkraft hält die Ampel
trotz Milliardenloch und ich freue mich
auf diese gästerunde Henrike Rossbach
ist wieder bei uns sie ist
Korrespondentin und stellvertretende
Büroleiterin der Süddeutschen Zeitung in
Berlin herzlich willkommen Christine
dankbar sie leitet das politikressort
der Frankfurter Rundschau ich begrüße
Reinhard Müller Ressortleiter
Zeitgeschehen und stat und recht bei der
Frankfurter Allgemeinen und stefan
Schulz ist bei uns freier Journalist
Podcaster herr Schulz Urteil mit SP mit
Sprengkraft haben wir über die Sendung
geschrieben Sprengkraft ist so ein
schönes Fantasie auslösendes Wort wie WE
kann diese Sprengkraft reichen also es
war tatsächlich Sprengkraft ich glaube
wir haben jetzt gerade so ein Sonntag wo
alle so gerusam zu Hause sitzen gerade
auch Politiker und Wissenschaftler od
Wirtschafts Wissenschaften die gerade
alle mal rekapitulieren was eigentlich
passiert ist die Woche weil man es in
dem Ausmaß wirklich nicht ganz
abschätzen kann 60 Milliarden das ist so
viel Geld man weiß jetzt gar nicht muss
man das adck plötzlich wiederfinden und
die Frage ist dann wo oder hat man da
jetzt ein bisschen Zeit dann hört man
irgendwie ja man kann den aktuellen
Haushalt erstmal machen aber es muss
jetzt auch als bald geschehen also es
bringt glaube ich einiges durcheinander
als ich dann auch mal so in ruhiger
Minute drüber nachdachte habe ich schon
festgestellt okay einfach nur so ein
paar Milliarden zusammenkratzen wir
haben es eigentlich mit Verwerfung zu
tun die uns vor Herausforderung stellen
fast so wie die Britten mit dem brexit
zu tun haben also man müsste fast ganze
Bundesministerien rausstreichen um auf
diese zig Milliarden zu kommen in der
Hinsicht ist das glaube ich jetzt so ein
ganz geruhsamer Tag noch mal vor großen
stürmen die jetzt auf uns zukommen
klingt fast unlö lösbar wie schätzen Sie
Frau dankbar die Sprengkraft ein was
sprengt dieses Urteil na ja die Frage
ist jetzt natürlich bzweise Tatsache ist
jetzt dass die Quadratur des Kreises
nicht mehr funktioniert bish er hat das
ja ganz gut geklappt weil ja jeder das
bekommen hat im Grunde was er haben
wollte von den fraktionären also spricht
die Grünen und die FDP und jetzt muss
man natürlich sich auf ganz neue
Verteilungskämpfe einstellen weil die 60
Milliarden von denen man dachte die
könnte man grusam ausgeben oder die
könnte man eben ausgeben für die in dem
klimat transformationsfond sind einfach
nicht mehr da und ich bin auch sehr
gespannt das wird bestimmt eine
interessante Zeit auch in den nächsten
Wochen schon weil es wird jetzt nicht es
muss jetzt nicht gleich sofort 60
Milliarden bis Weihnachten aufgetrieben
werden aber es ist schon so ich glaube
dass das auch schon 24 tangiert
zumindest ein Teil davon und ich
persönlich bin sehr gespannt wie
Christian Lindner das machen möchte mit
weniger Geld wirksamere Politik zu
machen das wird bestimmt sehr
interessant Frau Rossbach was sprengt
dieses Urteil das Urteil sprengt das
Hintertürchen dass die Regierung sich
geschaffen hatte also Konflikte die
eigentlich nicht zu überwinden sind die
Rolle des Staates wie soll sie sein ist
er ein Investor oder ist er derjenige
der nur Rahmen Bedingungen schafft die
eben dann private Investitionen
ermöglichen das sind die konträren
Haltung von grünen SPD und FDP und das
glaubt man überwinden zu können indem
man bei allen größeren Vorhaben wo das
Geld im Bundeshaushalt fehlte sagte na
gut dann zahlt das eben der Klima und
Transformation den haben wir ja gefüllt
und dieses Hintertürchen ist jetzt zu
allerdings würde ich sagen
dass die also die Koalition zu zu
sprengen zu verlassen sei es über
Neuwahlen oder den Versuch Friedrich
märz zu einer großen Koalition zu
bewegen ich glaube das ist für alle drei
Koalitionäre noch unattraktiver als die
Situation die sie jetzt vorfinden Herr
Müller was sagt der Jurist unter den
Journalisten in dieser Runde das sprengt
uns zurück in die Normalität in die nor
der Verfassung auch der schwbischen
Hausfrau es war ja jahrzehntelang so
dass wir eine wachsweiche Schuldenbremse
hatten aber die gab es schon immer wir
sollten ausgegleichene Haushalte
vorlegen und die wurde massiv missachtet
über die Jahre die haben riesen Berg von
Schulden angehäuft und die Politik hat
dann in einem Zehenring durch die
Föderalismusreform Bund und Länder
parteiübergreifend in die in Einsicht in
die eigene Fehlbarkeit die Fehlbarkeit
der Tagespolitik die Fehlbarkeit des
Denkens in Legislaturperioden diese
Schuldenbremse gemacht so gesehen selbst
scharf gestellt und das
Verfassungsgericht hat sie im re
angewendet und wenn jetzt so getan wird
auch Herr Harbeck als ob das aus
heiterem Himmel kommt als ob uns
irgendwelche Außerirdischen was
aufzwingen oder Verfassungsrichter die
aus dem Ruder laufen ist das alles
Blödsinn es ist so man konnte hätte es
wissen müssen nach dieser Schuldenbremse
es kommt jetzt genau das was die Ampel
verdient hat danke dass Sie dabei sind
in den sozialen Netzwerken und fleißig
kommentieren und viele Fragen stellen
eine Frage die in unserem Kanal bei X
immer wieder
auskommt wie kann es sein Sie haben es
gerade angesprochen Herr Müller dass ein
solches Haushaltsgesetz wo schon der
Bundesrechnungshof Fragezeichen dran
gemacht hat wo das
bundesverfassungsricht so eindeutig der
Ansicht ist das geht nicht das darf man
nicht das ist verboten äh dass es
trotzdem verabschiedet wird dass die
Bundesregierung das macht der politische
Wille ist halt größer und zeigt sich der
alte Fehler von der weichen
Schuldenbremse man macht immer weiter so
jetzt sind natürlich Corona war eine
sonderkrise aber die anderen Aufgaben
sind im Grunde daueraufgaben die der
Staat also auch Verteidigung eigentlich
Verteidigung Klimaschutz sind staatliche
daueraufgaben die aus dem normalen Etat
normalerweise bewältigt werden müssen
Corona war die Sondersituation aber hier
wurde ja gerade getrixt aber es scheint
ich meine es gibt auch User die fragen
wer ist da eigentlich verantwortlich ähm
der Finanzminister
das ist doch eine Blamage das scheint ja
eine eine sehr rote Linie zu sein also
Juristen sind nicht wirklich überrascht
also ähm warum ist er nicht bei Rot
gebremst worden Herr Schul Frau Rossbach
und Frau dankbar die Überraschung sind
groß weil auch der Geldbetrag groß ist
und jetzt große Fragen daraus kommen
aber die Schuldenbremse wurde bedingt
gestärkt ich halte das Urteil auch als
juristischer Leihe für äh sehr wichtig
und auch sehr plausibel also ist eins
was mir in 5 Minuten erklärt wird und
ich verstehe es sofort und ich denke
auch es war relevant dass es jetzt in
dieser Zeit kommt aber es ist kein
Urteil dass uns irgendwie beim Schulden
machen oder so jetzt noch mal die Bremse
reinhaut sondern erstmal sagt es nur die
Umwidmung von schon erteilten
kreditermächtigung die kann nicht
einfach so geschehen man kann nicht aus
einer Corona Notlage plötzlich äh über
ein klimaumweg auch noch dann
irgendwelche Chipfabriken bauen so und
in derhinsicht ist dieses durchaus noch
mal auch in der hinicht zu prüfen klar
ich will jetzt auch nicht dass eine
etwas merkwürdige finanzkonstruktion
gegen andere ersetzt wird aber wir haben
ein Urteil zur Schuldenbremse das aber
jetzt nicht unbedingt sagt die
Schuldenbremse muss immer greifen
sondern wenn man Schulden macht muss man
sachbezogen begründen für was und kann
dann nicht später umswitchen aber das
heißt nicht dass man künf der Begründung
für Schulden da irgendwie ein Riel
vorgeschoben hat also ich bin no bei der
Frage ähm deutlich erkennbare rote Linie
fahrlässig oder vielleicht sogar mit
Vorsatz Frau Rossbach wir hören mal kurz
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz für wenige
Sekunden zu diese Woche im Bundestag der
tut als sei er überrascht und könnne er
das ganze noch gar nicht richtig
einordnen alle waren bis jetzt der
Überzeugung dass das auch ein
ordentliches korrektes Vorgehen ist ich
finde es ist gut dass wir eine
Verfassungsordnung haben der das
Bundesverfassungsgericht spricht und ich
bin auch sehr stolz darauf dass wir die
Urteile auch dann beachten wenn wir
vorher anderer Meinung
waren also ähm dass der Regierungschef
sagt er sei stolz darauf das Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts zu beachten
ich bin nicht sicher ob er das noch mal
so sagen würde weil das ist natürlich
eine Selbstverständlichkeit also wenn
das nicht so wäre wenn diese Regierung
sich über dieses Urteil hinwegsetzen
würde das würde natürlich äh alles in
Frage stellen ja aber tatsächlich wenn
man sich jetzt vor diesem Mittwoch ein
bisschen umgehört hat in Berlin da
sagten die meisten Regierungsvertreter
wir rechnen mit irgendwas in der Mitte
zwischen alles okay weiter so und
rückwirkend nichtig diese letzte
Variante rückwirkend nichtig die hielten
doch die allermeisten für
unwahrscheinlich was auch daran liegt
dass z.B was eingetreten ist genau was
aber z.B auch daran liegt dass auch die
große Koalition schon mal in
zweistelligen Milliarden Betrag in so
einer Art frontloading also sich das
gepolstert hat für schlechtere Zeiten
und schon Verch hat das hatten die auch
schon mal gemacht es ist allerdings noch
nie sozusagen höchstrichterlich wirklich
entschieden worden ja den Ländern schon
wel ergzen darf genau es gab Urteile in
den Ländern aber aber eben noch nicht in
Karlsruhe und auch nicht in dieser
komplexen Frage aber ich glaube das das
heißt wir haben es mit
gewohnheitsmäßigem Rechtsbruch zu tun
wir haben es damit zu tun dass in der
Politik zum einen dieser Gedanke sehr
stark ist es kann nicht sein was nicht
sein darf ja also es es muss es muss
gehen weil eine andere Möglichkeit haben
wir nicht unsere Politik zu machen wird
schon irgendwie schiefgehen ja also der
Wunsch das zum Gelingen zu bringen ist
so groß dass man vielleicht dann auch
die Warnsignale nicht hören will und zum
anderen gab es eben schon seit vielen
Jahren die Praxis Sondervermögen
einzurichten für dieses und jenes und
daran hat man sich gewöhnt auch in den
eurokrisen und so wurden ja eben diese
Stabilisierungsfonds und so weiter
eingerichtet und man hatte sich daran
gewöhnt dass das ein Ausweg ist da
irgendwie durch zu kommen und dachte es
wird schon schief gehen ich spege immer
links ab an der Stelle obwohl es
verboten ist es mal hört das natürlich
beim Kanzler dass sie absolut überrascht
waren und dass da auch so ein so ein
Schockmoment ist aber äh und die es war
ja auch sozusagen so ein bisschen
gelebte Praxis mit diesen Sondervermögen
die aber auch immer kritisiert wurden
also dass sie so überrascht sind ist
dann aber wahrscheinlich auch weil es
fürnichtig erklärt wurde wahrscheinlich
hatten die damit gerechnet dass sie eine
Rüge bekommen und dass es dann für
künftige Haushalte äh praktiziert werden
muss aber es ist ja jetzt auch nicht so
dass diese man muss sich das auch mal an
dass juristisch ist mir das auch
einsichtig und ich sehe das auch nicht
so dass jetzt äh dass man jetzt nie
wieder Geld aufnehmen kann für diese
Sachen sondern man muss es eben anders
begründen und man muss es jährlicher
begründen und jährlicher in den Haushalt
einstellen aber es ist ja auch ungelogen
politisch haben wir eine äh wie man es
auch definieren mag haben wir eine
Notlage haben wir also wir haben keine
Normalzeiten und deswegen bin ich
wirklich ich hätte nie gedacht dass ich
der schwäbischen Hausfrau mal wieder
begegne in einer Diskussion weil ich
schon finde dass wir Milliarden auch
brauchen um den Staat zu transformieren
und auch wenn das jetzt zunehmend nach
zwei Jahren hohler klingt es ist
trotzdem wahr da ist ja auch ein
Reformstau der aufgearbeitet werden mus
jetzt tauchen wir von der
Haushaltspolitik mal runter ins richtige
Leben viele Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
stellen sich die Frage was bedeutet das
jetzt und Robert habbeck ist in einer
Befragung des Bundestags im Juni also
vor einem knappen halben Jahr schon mal
genau diese Frage Frage gestellt worden
wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht das
Ganze für nichtig erklären würde welche
Folgen hätte das das in der Tat würde
bedeuten dass uns der Fußboden
weggezogen wird auf dem wir versuchen
die wirtschaftliche Situation in
Deutschland Stab zu stabilisieren wenn
diese Klage erfolgreich ist das würde
Deutschland wirklich
wirtschaftspolitisch hart hart treffen
wahrscheinlich so hart dass wir das
nicht bestehen werden was bedeutet das
jetzt Herr Müller Herr schz man muss
sich ja mal vergegenwertigen wir rechnen
mit bis 2025 mit Steuereinnahmen von
1000 Milliarden man kann auch die Frage
stellen ob wir nicht trotz der ganzen
Krisen die wir auch als Chancen sehen
kann aus dem aus diesem Geld schon
allein Haushalt bestreiten können und
diese Äußerung ist zeigt irendwie die
Verantwortungslosigkeit bisheriger
Politik aber auch dass man nicht 60
Milliarden die man ja Strecken kann man
kann anders wo einschichten man kann
noch mal das als Chance nehmen drüber
nachzudenken wo wir ganz grundleegende
reichenstellung anders machen also man
könnte es wirklich als Chance begreifen
dass man jetzt bei 1000 Milliarden
erwarteten Einnahmen über 60 Milliarden
in dieser Konstellation behauptet
alles bricht zusammen halte ich für
übertrieben ja aber wir sagen jetzt
häufiger wir hören es ja nicht zum
ersten Mal in dieser Runde das Urteil
hat uns überrascht wie konnte man das
vorher wissen sie haben sie auch noch
mal bestärkt aber vor zi Jahren hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht geurteilt dass
es ein Recht auf Zukunft gibt und wir
nicht jede klimapolitische Maßnahmen
nach 2035 konkretisieren können so dann
hat Herr habeg als grünvertreter
natürlich auch Kopernikus das EU Klima
die klimaagenturen Blick die jetzt für
dieses Jahr attestiert wir sind bei 1,43
Grad also kurz vor der für uns auch
völkerrechtlichen über das parisabkommen
Binden
1,5° wo ich denke okay wir haben
eigentlich eine Notlage also wir haben
zum einen den bundesverfassungsauftrag
Recht auf Zukunft wir müssen jetzt
Klimapolitik machen und wir haben eine
Notlage weil wir das 1,5° Ziel schon
erreichen rechtfertigt das nicht ein
Sonderhaushalt aufzubauen den auch über
Verschuldung zu machen also nicht erst
in der im Haushalt zu fragen ja müssen
wir jetzt die Renten um 20% senken das
sind ja ungefähr die 60 Milliarden so
auf der Ebene spielen wir da also geht
relevant greift in jeden Alltag ein und
da würde ich schon sagen okay man kann
jetzt überrascht sein von dem Urteil und
man sollte aber nicht diejenigen die
vorher Argumente dafür fanden dass man
vielleicht doch jetzt akute auch
Notlagen getriggerte also dann wirklich
über den schuldenbrem klimawand ist eine
akute Daueraufgabe die schon länger
bekannt ist und das sind beides Urteile
zur Nachhaltigkeit das klimaurteil und
das hier ist ja auch ein nachhaltiges
Urteil weil wir künftien Generation 40
Milliarden Zinsen im Jahr jetzt schon
Luft zum Atmen geben wollen auch um den
klimaf uns einmal noch mal also
Perspektive aller die nicht
Haushaltsrecht studiert haben oder in
Berlin in Ausschüssen sitzen und als
Journalistin zuhören ist ja was heißt
das jetzt für mich die erste Nachricht
die kam war das Restaurantbesuche am 1
Januar teurer werden ich muss dort für
Essen wieder 19% Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen
ähm in den Kommentaren ist z.B die Frage
was ist jetzt mit den Zuschüssen die mir
für Heizungsmodernisierung zugesagt
wurden gelten die noch in Magdeburg und
Dresden wo äh 15 Milliarden Euro für
zwei Chipfabriken aus dem Bundeshaushalt
subventioniert werden sollen fragt man
sich kommen die jetzt noch also ganz
konkret was ist absehbar was glauben sie
wird als erstes gestrichen um ein
bisschen in das Loch wieder
reinzuschütten also das ist relativ
schwierig zu sagen weil das wird ja
natürlich ausgehandelt werden was ja
schnell
versichert wurde ist dass die förder
die beschlossenen Fördermaßnahmen oder
dass man eben fördert beim
heizungsausbau dass es auf jeden Fall
kommen soll dass es
sehr schnell
noch am gleichen Tag versichert worden
also ich würde ich mal sagen diese
Maßnahmen sind in in dem Zusammenhang
vielleicht sie sind dann schon sicher
aber bei Intel würde ich schon sagen da
müsste man einfach mal gucken das ist
mit Sicherheit wieder auf dem Tisch weil
wenn da jetzt noch kein Vertrag
unterzeichnet genau das ist die
Milliarden die mit Milliarden
Subventionen eben unterstützt werden
soll das ist mit Sicherheit wieder
fraglicher geworden ich finde auch der
Bahnausbau ist wieder fraglicher
geworden das sind ja auch
Absichtserklärungen und so man will das
ich glaube das mit dem unseligen
heizungsgesetz will man da wenigstens
nicht noch mal irgendwie eine Baustelle
aufmachen scheint mir auch vernünftig zu
sein aber alles andere was jetzt noch
nicht wurde jetzt noch nicht in Haken
dran ist wo noch nicht Verpflichtungen
eingegangen sind das ist
selbstverständlich wieder auf dem Tisch
und wird jetzt verhandelt werden und mit
entsprechenden Sprengkraft der Ampel
weil ich bin schon der Meinung dass die
Beteiligten unterschiedliche Interessen
haben was wichtig
ist ja also ich würde auch sagen mag ich
gucke sie an weil sie die Sitzungen des
Haushaltsausschusses so genau beobachten
ja also es war tatsächlich am Donnerstag
war reinigungssitzung das ist diese
traditionelle Sitzung die bis in die
Morgenstunden geht wo die Haushälter den
Haushalt fürs nächste Jahr fertig
verschnüren und die letzten Milliarden
von diesem Millionen eher von diesem
Projekt so jenem schieben und dieses
Jahr wurde eben kein Strich drunter
gemacht weil man gesagt hat wir können
wegen des Urteils viele Dinge einfach
noch nicht final jetzt hier beraten und
beschließen weil wir manches auch noch
nicht wissen z.B wissen wir nicht geht's
jetzt nur um den klimafond oder ist auch
unser wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond
betroffen mit dem haben wir ja den
doppelwums bezahlt den berühmten die
Strom- und gaspreisbremse und was da an
Geld geflossen ist im vergangenen Jahr
das müsste ja wenn das auch rückwirkend
nichtig ist müsste das auf die
Schuldenbremse zählen das würde dazu
führen dass der Haushalt so wie er
beschlossen war konstruiert war nicht
funktioniert hätte und das sind Fragen
die sind offen jetzt hofft man dass man
das das das heißt ich will nur will nur
einmal zusammenfassen also wir haben
eine relative ungewisshit was an
Leistungen für uns Bürgerinnen und
Bürger beschnitten verändert
zurückgenommen wird was an Subventionen
und Förderung für die Wirtschaft
passiert wir glauben zu wissen dass die
Bundesregierung das Thema
Heizungserneuerung Gebäudesanierung
nicht noch mal anfassen will also das
ist sozusagen gesichert aber ansonsten
große Unsicherheit dann haben sie gerade
in einem Nebensatz fast etwas gesagt was
vielleicht noch größere Bedeutung hat
es gibt 29 Sondervermögen auf Bundes
Ebene ganz viele in den Ländern hier ist
nur über eines gesprochen worden also
wir wissen auch noch gar nicht wie groß
das Ausmaß am Ende wirklich ist sind
sofort dran Herr Müller und Herr Schulz
kann es sein die Frage gebe ich Ihnen
noch mit dass uns passiert was wir aus
den USA kennen dass am 1 Januar die
Heizungen in den Behörden ausgemacht
werden weil es keinen Bundeshaushalt
gibt glaube ich nicht aber der
doppelbumes ist natürlich schon eine
andere Dimension da muss man erstmal
prüfen das macht ja die Union ist es
vergleichbar aber gibt's ein paar
Anhaltspunkte das ist auch ähnliche
Probleme gibt dann wäre die Frage ob die
Rechtsfolge gleich ist wenn man dagegen
nach karlswur zieht aber ich glaube wenn
wir Beispiel Mehrwertsteuer für
gastwürte das ist wieder so nebenens
Schauplatz der natürlich bedeutungsvoll
ist und auch was bringt für gastwürte
für Esser für gourmes aber man könnte
doch noch mal grundsätzlich so eine
staatliche Aufgabenkritik machen was
muss Pizza glaub ich was muss der Staat
leisten und was was muss er nicht
leisten können wir bei der Migration
können wir im Sozialstaat noch
Stellschrauben drehen Frau Esen hat ja
gleich gesagt Klima und Sozialstaat
unantastbar und das halte ich schon für
den ersten falschen Schritt auch für
unverantwortlich man könnte doch dieser
Lage sagen wir gucken genau wo ähm ist
sind subvensionen nicht zielgenau können
wir den Staat stärker und schlanker
zugleich machen das ist eine einmalige
Chance auch ja ich finde auch also auch
die Aussage von habck das sozusagen
dieses Land den Bach runtergeht wenn wir
nicht zusätzlich zu unserem gigantischen
Bundeshaushalt uns noch irgendwelche ext
Töpfe sichern die wir dann aber
irgendwie anders abrechnen das finde ich
schon ist ja eigentlich auch so eine Art
Offenbarungseid weil ich meine verteil
innere äußere Sicherheit das sind
natürlich die Kernaufgaben des Staates
und die müssen natürlich aus dem
Kernhaushalt bezahlt werden dass man in
der Vergangenheit das eine sich von den
USA hat sichern lassen und das andere
fand man nicht so wichtig und dass die
große Koalition unfassbare
Rentenreformen gemacht haben die auf
viele Jahre hinaus mit Milliarden mehr
Ausgaben bedeuten und dass das alles
immer so gelassen wird rentenzuschüs aus
dem bundeshausalt bewegen sich in
Richtung 150 Milliarden genau wir sind
jetzt schon bei über 100 Milliarden
100enst milliensen ja also wir reden
über 6 Milliarden aber wir zahlen 40
Milliarden Zinsen D wird immer sie haben
vor die Rente erwähnt natürlich wird die
Rente nicht gekürzt weil wir jetzt die
60 Milliarden nicht mehr haben
gite also das das aber es sind die
Relationen ja und Schulz fr dankbar die
Relationen sind ja viel größer als wir
glauben wenn jetzt wirklich alles über
den Bundes also den Kernhaushalt wie wir
so schon sagen abgerechnet werden muss
und wir wollen bei der Klimapolitik wie
sie sie jetzt vereinbart haben bleiben
und nur mal so theoretisch im Kopf wir
müssen jetzt die 60 Milliarden adthck
anders finanzieren aus dem
Bundeshaushalt und bleiben aber bei der
Rente und bei der Verteidigung gnadenlos
diese Gelder werden bezahlt selbst wenn
wir Bildung und Forschung Gesundheit
Ernährung Familien und wohn komplett
streichen also die ganzen
Bundesministerien komplett rausnehmen
haben wir dieses 60 Milliarden Ziel noch
nicht erreicht und das 60 Milliarden
Ziel ist nicht auf ein Kön nicht stehen
lassen 60 Milliarden sie reden jetzt
davon was was die einzelnen et im Jahr
kosten und setzen das gleich mit einem
auf viele Jahre angelegten
Sondervermögen das nicht in einem Jahr
ausgezahlt werden soll das sogar nach
weitere wo jetzt die Rechtsgutachten von
März angefordert werden und er dann
überlegt wie geht er denn damit als
Beispiel für die Dimensionen bringen Sie
Ihren Gedanken zu Ende dann ist Verg ja
wenn wir solche Diskussion haben also
entweder - 20% bei allen Renten oder wir
nehmen ganze Bundesministerien raus oder
wir kippen komplett die Klimapolitik und
wir haben aber ein Bundestag der nicht
kompromissfähig ist sondern der schon im
Wahlkampfmodus in Lager gespar wo man
auch die Kern also quasi nur noch die
Kernmarke Schuldenbremse durchfechten
möchte ohne inhitliche Argumentation
dann stehen wir wirklich vor einem
Problem wie in Amerika dass wir
Parlament haben dass sich einfach selbst
blockiert dass wir eine vetocracy haben
in der noch Vetos ausgesprochen werden
und ein Popanz für Youtube Kameras
aufgeführt wird aber wir weder zu einer
haushaltsfindung kommen noch ein
Wahlkampf organisieren können fr also
ich finde nicht dass wir darüber
diskutieren gerade
20% weniger Renten in Deutschland das
sehe ich nicht so und ich sehe die diese
Dramatik auch nicht auch nicht so wie
bei Robert habbeck der hat
wahrscheinlich eher gedacht wie vieler
mit seinem mit seinem Koalitionspartner
dann wieder zusammen reden und
verhandeln müsste und da kann ich die
persönliche Dramatik verstehen aber die
was den Staatshaushalt betrifft
es ist ja nicht so dass der
transformationsf leer ist also der ist
ja gefüllt es gibt auch Einnahmen die da
reinfließen CO2 Preis das ist also nicht
der Fall dass jetzt
komplett auf soziale Sicherung das
komplett auf
kl Politik verzichtet werden muss das
ist nicht der Fall also ich sehe es
nicht so dramatisch ich sehe es aber
auch nicht so positiv wie Sie dass ich
sagen das ist jetzt eine prima
Gelegenheit in St irgendwie oder eine
Chance zu sehen ist natürlich wunderbar
wenn man bisschen Optimismus verbreitet
aber es ist natürlich klar dass jetzt
einfach mal wieder wenn wir jetzt eine
große Koalition hätten nicht dass ich
eine Anhängerin den wä aber dann könnte
ich mir vorstellen da würden die
Verhandlungen anders laufen aber jetzt
ist es doch wieder die fliegkräfte
zwischen grün und FDP und da steh stelle
ich mir das stelle ich mir die nächsten
Diskussionen einfach nicht so
konstruktiv vor deswegen bin ich was das
betrifft auch wieder ein bisschen
pessimistisch ich nehme mal drei
Diskussionen also jemand bitte einer
Halbsatz eine Antwort in einem halben
Satz warum werden die Objektiv sehr sehr
sinnvollen Vermögenssteuern so wenig
diskutiert fragt Stefan geierer kommt
eine
vermögenssteuererhöhung nein Einführung
wie auch immer nein wird das Urteil das
ist eine Frage die ist eigentlich schon
beantwortet worden aber so wichtig dass
wir sie noch mal klarstellen können wird
das Urteil Auswirkungen auf die
Rentenhöhe von regelalters Rentnern
haben ja wird es nein also wir haben
politische Beratungskräfte die kennen
sie alle von Christian Lindner wo die
Rente jetzt schon als Thema auf dem
Tisch liegt
sot genau also das ist ja nur was
anderes es geht darum dass man überlegen
muss ob solche Reformen wie die Rente
mit 63 die in jeder Hinsicht
kontraproduktiv und falsch waren und
viel teurer geworden sind als sich das
die Beteiligten damals gedacht haben ob
man sowas für immer weiterlaufen lassen
muss und im übrigen wird auch bei den
Diskussionen um die Haltelinien geht's
nicht um die Höhe der Renten dass die
Rentenbezüge sinken sollen sondern nur
um das Verhältnis ja andere Meinung also
wir bezahlen im Jahr 350 Milliarden
Rente ein Drittel davon kommt aus dem
Bundeshaushalt muss also jedes Jahr
wieder im Haushalt verabschiedet werden
über die halterlinien wie auch immer
haben wir so ein bisschen Konstanz
drinne aber wir übersehen nur weil wir
als Journalisten nicht diskutieren dass
jedes Jahr die Renten auch im Bundestag
in der Höhe neu beschlossen werden
müssen übersehen wir dass es trotzdem
jedes Jahr als Entscheidung stattfindet
okay ich dachte was ich Seher ich hatte
gehofft die Frage sei weniger komplex
ich versuche noch eine ähm ein User auf
Facebook warum lösen wir das
Dienstwagenprivileg nicht auf davon
profitieren sowieso nur die die sich
Autos auch sonst schon leisten können
und das würde 5 Milliarden bringen das
ist aber wie mit der Mehrwertsteuer bei
den bei den Gaststätten natürlich kann
man das machen und so klar also viel
äh viel hilft viel wenn man wenn man das
addiert ähm es ist natürlich so ähm dass
wird dann natürlich wird es wieder
Diskussion geben sie haben sie ja schon
vorgelesen was jetzt wenn der Schnitzel
teurer wird für eine Diskussion gibt und
das Dienstwagenprivileg da geht es ja
darum dass man das als geldwerten
Vorteil versteuert aber nicht so viel
wie es wirklich bringt wenn man das
privat nutzt den Dienstwagen klar
betrifft es die Leute die in Dienstwagen
haben persönlich habe keinen weiß kein
nicht wer hier am Tisch einen hat aber
man kann es natürlich erhöhen klar aber
man kann natürlich auch steuern dass man
sagen vielleicht nur noch für
Elektroautos es wird ein paar Milliarden
bringen aber es wird nicht den
entscheidenden ich hab die Beispiele
Herr M sie können gerne aufgreifen ich
will nur sagen ich habe die Beispiele
genannt weil sie die Unsicherheit
darstellen alles scheint auf dem Tisch
zu liegen große Unklarheit sie haben das
eingangs richtig beschrieben herr Scholz
wenn wir es etwas größer ziehen Herr
Müller geht's ja um die Frage
kann der Staat jetzt einen anderen Weg
finden um sich Geld zu besorgen für
Klimaschutz für Umbau der Wirtschaft
oder kommen wir jetzt in die Situation
das wirklich deutlich weniger Geld zur
Verfügung steht und er könnte do die
schuldenbem streichen wenn er die
Mehrheit hat das finde ich auch armselig
weil die der Sache nach notwendig ist er
könnte natürlich die Schuldenbremse
ändern er könnte auch eine neue Notlage
erfinden aber ich glaube da sind die
Regeln relativ klar man kann den
Klimawandel jetzt nicht zur
außergewöhnlichen Notlage adthck machen
ich glaube aber weil wir gerade
gesprochen hatten über die fliegkräfte
die es ja gibt in dieser Konstellation
in dieser Koalition die zwingen
natürlich auch also diese dieses Urteil
zwingt dazu dass sie sich zusammenraufen
wenn Sie die Koalition nicht sprengen
wollen wofür ich im Moment auch nicht
mehr Interessen sehe als z zu bleiben
sie müssen sich einigen und jeder muss
glaube ich nachgeben also man kann nicht
sagen es wird überhaupt keine Steuer
erhöht es wird nichts am Sozialstaat
gemacht es wird nichts Klima gemacht man
könnte aber auch wenn ich sage neu
denken noch mal fragen Atomkraft ist
vielleicht billiger also das Undenkbare
denken was bei harberg im Haus glaube
ich auch intern gemacht wird ganz neue
Wege jenseits dieser Einzelmaßnahmen die
wir jetzt aufzählen die aber gar nicht
so viel bringen das sind ja so alte Hüte
dienwagen Privileg und schnitzelsteuer
wie auch immer sondern noch mal
grundlegend ist auch der Klimaschutz
muss der so teuer sein um effektiv zu
sein also die Schuldenbremse steht
nichtter Disposition niemand fordert
ihre Abschaffung und auch wenn wir sie
im deutschen Grundgesetz abschaffen
haben wir EU-Regeln die uns binden aber
die Schuldenbremse hat ja sozusagen
abfedernde Kraft indem sie
beispielsweise Notlagen definiert oder
eine konjunkturkomponente drin hat sie
hat aber kein Vorsorgeprinzip bis heute
drin und wir haben mit dem Klima aber
ein Thema das vorsorgekalkulation die
genauso volkswirtschaftlich
durchgerechnet werden können wie die
konjunkturkomponente das ist eine
wahnsinnig komplizierte Rechnung die
wahrscheinlich dann wirklich kein Leier
versteht genauso so kann man das mit dem
Klima auch machen insbesondere weil wir
ja völkerrechtlich gebunden sind an
Klimapolitik jetzt sieht's ja so aus als
hätten wir die Klimapolitik die wir
haben im KTF in so einer Art badbank
ausgelagert und der ziehen wir dann
einfach den der KTF ist der Fond der
gerade um 60 Milliarden ausgekippt der
jetzt wirklich sehr zusammengeschrumpft
ist aber da ist ja auch eine fast
15-jährige Erfolgsgeschichte so und wir
haben damit eigentlich ein Instrument
bei dem man fast sagen Kön es ist noch
so ein staatlicher Obhut aber es ist
schon so unternehmerische Intelligenz um
sich dann wirklich Rendite orientiert
mit Klimaschutz zu beschäftigen so also
was das so im Kernhaushalt zu tun hat
ist eh eine Diskussion jetzt sagt das
Bundesverfassungsgericht es muss alles
im Kernhaushalt verrechnet werden aber
das natürlich erstmal nur eine
juristische Argumentation auch keine
inhaltliche also man kann ja politisch
genau so nachsteuern und sagen dann
finden wir jetzt eine inhalliche
Argumentation nur ich würde sagen okay
bisher haben wir viel über Notsituation
geregelt Schulden sonderhaushaltig
argumentiert weil wir eine Notsituation
haben und wir brauchen das
Vorsorgeprinzip da genauso stark drin
dahinter äh steckt dieses Wort
Schuldenbremse ist ein Gesetz das 2009
äh verabschiedet worden ist bzw eine
Änderung des Grundgesetzes die 2009
verabschiedet worden ist ähm die besagt
dass ungefähr ein Drittel Prozent der
jährlichen Wirtschaftsleistung als
Schulden im Bundeshaushalt aufgenommen
werden darf und die Diskussion die Herr
Müller und Herr Schulz gerade geführt
haben Frau Rossbach lese ich jetzt auch
in den Zeitungen Michael Hüter der Chef
des Instituts der deutschen Wirtschaft
also ein wirtschaftsnaher äh
Wissenschaftler sagt ja 2009 gab es
viele Krisen und Umstände noch nicht die
wir heute haben man muss das Überdenken
wir brauchen tatsächlich mehr Geld für
Investitionen also ist es richtig und
nötig diese Schuldenbremse
nicht immer wieder zu umgehen sondern
das Gesetz selbst zu ändern also
grundsätzlich glaube ich dass es im
Moment erstmal nicht möglich ist weil
wir dafür keine zweirittel Mehrheit im
Bundestag das W die zweite Frage aber
inhaltlich kann man natürlich darüber
nachdenken ob man an der Schuldenbremse
an einigen Stellschrauben dreht man
könnte sich z.B sie haben gerade dieses
berühmte drittelpzent angesprochen man
könnte z.B diesen Satz einfach leicht
erhöhen das würde laut Berechnung von
Ökonomen immer noch dazu führen dass
unsere gesamtstatliche Verschuldung
sinkt also dass wir auf einem sinkenden
pfahrt sind nur halt nicht mehr so steil
sinken sondern flacher das wäre z.B eine
Möglichkeit dann wäre das grundsätzliche
Wirken der Schuldenbremse nicht in Frage
gestellt man hätte aber mehr Spielraum
man könnte überlegen ob es Ausnahmen
gibt für Investitionen das halte ich
aber für sehr Sch schwierig weil die
Definition was eine Investition ist die
geht die kann man natürlich
volkswirtschaftlich ist es Glas klar
aber politisch ist es natürlich einer
der lieblingsbegriffe von von allen
politischen Akteuren also wenn sie in
der SPD Fragen dann sagen die die das
Bürgergeld ist eine Investition
Investition in den sozialen Frieden in
die soziale Sicherung aber es ist
natürlich keine Investition und das
Modell ist eben auch geschalt über
jahrzehte das war der GR gen es wird es
würde dann solche
Abgrenzungsschwierigkeiten geben so wie
die Regierung jetzt in diesem klimafond
auch lauter Dinge reingeschoben hat die
wirklich nur mit einer großen Krücke als
äh investives staatliches Eingreifen mit
Blick auf Zukunft klimarün
gedeutet werden kann so würde dann eben
auch gesagt ja aber vielleicht die
Justizbeamten die sind doch eigentlich
auch eine Investition weil damit
schaffen wir dann die Möglichkeiten uns
Puffer zu verschaffen Immigration und so
weiter und diese Tür aufzumachen halte
ich für wirklich gefährlich wenn man ein
Mechanismus der Schuldenbremse so wie
sie ist was ändert an den Werten oder so
das kann ich mir vorstellen oder dass
man es gibt auch die Idee z.B dass man
schaut wie groß ist der Anteil der
Zinsen die wir zahlen ja also und dass
man da so eine Relation festlegt die
nicht überschritten werden darf damit
man eben nicht wieder dahinkommt wo wir
früher waren Zinsen zweitgrößter Posten
im Bundeshaushalt fast keine Spielräume
mehr Frau dankbar und dann Herr Müller
also ist es sinnvoll notwendig
wünschenswert dass wir uns als
Gesellschaft mehr schuldengeld
genehmigen ja das klingt jetzt so ach
wir wollen noch mal so diesen berühmten
Schluck aus der Pulle aber in der Tat
ist es sinnvoll dass man die
Schuldenbremse bisschen flexibilisiert
denn die ist die gibt's jetzt schon eine
Weile und es ist es stimmt einfach dass
die Krisen die wir jetzt bekomt die
waren nicht absehbar und man muss auch
irgendwie drauf reagieren können und ich
bin persönlich schon der Meinung dass
die schuldenbremsepolitik dann zu sehr
einengt und das sieht man jetzt auch das
ist so ein bisschen
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat alle müssen
die auch sagen Schuldenbremse ist toll
wollen wir unbedingt haben das ist ja
auch so ein bisschen ist es schon auch
äh vorgeschoben ich glaube das im
Hintergrund dass man sich da auch ein
bisschen mehr über die Schuldenbremse
ärgert als das jetzt hier immer so ein
bisschen formuliert wird weil die FDP
findet sie ja bestätigt und finde es
ganz toll ich finde die schulenbremse so
wie sie jetzt ist nicht ganz toll weil
sie eben wie gesagt ne in äh einfach
Schulden an sich erstmal äh beschränkt
und damit auch Politik beschränkt und es
gibt ein Unterschied auch wenn man das
dann in der Definitionsfrage vielleicht
noch mal klären muss aber es gibt ein
Unterschied zwischen Konsumausgaben und
Investitionsausgaben und wenn man jetzt
hier ich glaube das werden wenige
bestreiten dass wir hier in der Phase
unseres States sind wo einfach ein
gewaltiger Umbau stattfinden muss
Stichwort dekarbonisierung und da muss
man natürlich auch steuern können und da
müssen auch muss auch äh flexibler auch
gehandhabt werden können ich sehe es
aber auch so dass es natürlich wird die
Schuldenbremse nicht abgeschafft die
Klagen ja nicht erst und dann schaffen
Sie sie gemeinsam ab also die Union also
insofern muss man denke ich auch dass
überall an den stellschraumben gedreht
wird und ich finde das richtig Herr
Müller es war ja nicht das
bundesverfassungsricht noch mal sondern
eine ganz Große Koalition Bund und
Ländern die eben gesehen haben es ging
so nicht die Vorstellung war früher wir
sparen anen guten Zeiten für die Krisen
nee aber das war doch das ist doch alles
nicht so überraschend die Bundeswehr und
so weiter es ist nicht so überraschend
und diese Schattenhaushalte wir häufen
ja jetzt schon so viel Schulden an den
paar Jahren wie wir in 70 Jahren vorher
angehäuft haben und der Rechnungshof hat
auch gesagt wir haben Kontrollverlust
wir werden über Jahrzehnte Zinsen zahlen
und ich glaube deswegen es wäre auch der
falsche Weg die auch aufzuweichen das wä
eine kleine Stellschraube konjunkturelle
ausnahmen sind jetzt schon mit
berücksichtigt und man kann ja auch die
Frage stellen müssen Krisen immer mit
sondertöpfen oder mit vielen Milliarden
bekämpft werden oder gibt's vielleicht
mehr Möglichkeiten die Freiheitlichen
Kräfte die Markt zuak eren also da auch
mal neu denken und nicht zu sagen Krise
heißt Geld Geld ausschütten also es ist
so eine Gefahr und das zeigt sich auch
in diesem Umtopfen dass ich dann top
aufmachchen der soll auch viel halten
vielleicht man könnte auch die die
Verfassung ändern das W übrigens auch
eine Möglichkeit aller Verteidigung wir
machen einen klimasonderfond in der
Verfassung sozusagen wir sagen 500
Milliarden fürs Klima aber ist das der
rich ist der Unterschied dass dieses
Geld für die Bundeswehr explizit in der
Verfassung ST weil die wen das geht
nicht mit
schattenhaus da war auch die Zustimmung
einzuholen das war natürlich so ich
würde ich würde gerne zum Schluss ä also
wir haben noch ein paar Minuten aber
auf die politischen Verhältnisse in
Berlin kommen wir müssen über die Ampel
sprechen aber ich glaube wir müssen auch
über die CDU CSU sprechen deren
Abgeordnete dieses Urteil erwirkt haben
Friedrich März triumphiert freut sich
gleichzeitig es ist schon erwähnt worden
gibt es durchaus auch CDU regierte
Bundesländer wie NRW und steswig
Holstein die ähnliches getan haben und
jetzt auch vor Schwierigkeiten kommen
und Friedrich März überlegt sogar noch
einen Schritt weiterzugehen und einen
noch größeren Fond in Frage zu stellen
in Karlsruher aus dem unter anderem das
Geld für unsere Strom und
gaspreisbremsen fließt
ja schauen wir mal also die Union steht
ja vielleicht sehr schnell vor der Frage
in die Ampel ersatzweise einzutreten
oder wird sich ja 2025 um die Führung
der Regierung bewerben und
ja warum warum macht sie das ist das
klug
Strategie also diese ganzen Kämpfe da in
Berlin ich weiß auch nicht ob wir uns
als Journalisten zu sehr die Köpfe der
Politiker zerbrechen sollten also deren
Berater oder sogar deren Spiel so
mitspielen klar die Herausforderung sind
riesig aber die CDU Fraktion hat es
durch diese Klage die ja wirklich von
der ganzen Fraktion getragen wurde ein
Urteil erwirkt das im Grunde auch sagt
es ist die Aufgabe des Parlaments jetzt
ja wieder grundlegend neu zu entscheiden
es kann aber alles entscheiden die
Schuldenbremse kann zur Disposition
gestellt werden wie auch immer oder es
können bedingungs und inhaltliche
Zusammenhänge für
Neuverschuldung gestellt werden dieses
Urteil ist zu wichtig und zu
weitreichend um das jetzt sofort in so
eine okay wir haben jetzt zwei Lager und
so weiter sondern die
Gesamtverantwortung ist so riesig und
wenn ich dann höre das Friedrich märz
als allererstes vorschlägt ja da muss
jetzt die Ampel ganz schön gucken wo sie
spart mein erster Vorschlag wä hat ja
dann Christian Siebers nach einer Minute
Nachfragen rausgekitzelt die
kindtergrundsicherung da sieht man wie
wenig Verantwortung auf Seiten der CDU
da ist weil jetzt einfach so ein 2
Milliarden Betrag thematisch in den Raum
zu stellen während man nicht nur den
nächsten Haushalt sondern das ganze
Gefüge von wie finanzieren wir diesen
Staat welcheer Verantwortung müssen die
Politiker jetzt noch wieder neu
übernehmen wir haben das ja während
Corona gehabt wir hatten diese
Schattenhaushalte dann hatten wir diese
bundländerrunden alles nicht
verfassungsrechtlich irgendwo so
festgeschrieben wie man sich das wünscht
jetzt hab wir das
Bundesverfassungsgericht das in diesem
sehr plausiblen Urteil sagt der
Bundestag muss es entscheiden und ich
würde sagen die Aufgabe ist so riesig
dass man vielleicht mit diesem Lagern
ein bisschen warten muss auch wenn ich
natürlich weiß wie schwierig das ist die
Wahlkämpfe stehen an wir haben die CDU
als der riesige Oppositionspartei die
sich auch immer noch mit Opposition
quasi zweiter Opposition AFD
herumschlagen muss aber vielleicht
findet man noch irgendwo so ein Weg ein
bisschen drüber zu stehen die
Verantwortung wirklich ernst dan also
ich finde erstmal ist das die Aufgabe
der Opposition und der Union wenn sie
der Meinung ist dass das was die
Regierung gemacht hat falsch ist und es
ist ja auch bei vielen dann genau dann
ist es ganz normal das das üblich was
die was ich von der Opposition im
Bundestag erwarte sonst funktioniert das
Ganze nämlich nicht und natürlich wird
Friedrich März wenn er jetzt noch den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsf wenn das
dann auch noch gekippt werden sollte
wird er im nächsten Wahlkampf erklären
müssen wie er Politik machen will wenn
es kein finanziellen Spielraum gibt also
insofern stehen alle wieder vor den
gleichen Dingen das finde ich jetzt auch
will er den im Kern sag mal die Kasse
kleiner machen und weniger Geld ausgeben
oder will er im Kern die Regierung vor
sich hertreiben und der zeigen dass sie
ihren Job nicht gut ma also kurzfristig
erst mal wahrscheinlich letzteres weil
das natürlich se die Aufgabe der Union
ist als Oppositionsfraktion hat ja lange
ein bisschen gebraucht bis sie
angekommen ist jetzt sch ist natürlich
klar weil das ist ja jetzt auch im
aufwend da genießt man das natürlich und
da ist ist natürlich auch ein so ein
gewisses ich habe aber den Eindruck dass
er so nach dem ersten nach der ersten
Freude und dem ersten Triumph dann auch
schon bisschen runtergedimmt hat um das
weil das auch klar ist das hat Folgen
also das hat man hat man finde ich schon
gemerkt dann auch bei den bei den
weiteren Äußerungen aber Tatsache ist
natürlich wenn wenn es
verfassungswidrig ist muss es geändert
werden das heißt ja jetzt noch lange
nicht dass wir
dass es so dramatisch ist wie Robert
habck uns das erklärt hat jedenfalls
nicht aus diesen Gründen und was jetzt
mal Staatsverschuldung betrifft da sind
wir aber im euvergleich gar nicht so
schlecht sind bei dem Thema nicht mehr
sondern wir sind beiim letzten kurzen
Ausblick auf die noch verbleibenden zwei
Jahre dieser Regierung wird sie einen
neuen Kurs finden die Ampel ich glaube
ja sie ist zwar so gesehen jetzt auf
einen Verfassungsbruch gebraut das war
so eine Art Geschäftsgrundlage der Ampel
diese Konstruktion aber ich glaube es
sind auch große Kräfte da das Interesse
da zusammen zuu biben ist nicht zu
unterschätzen vielleicht größer als das
Interesse dass jemand abspringt
Neuwahlen da müsste schon eine große
Hüde besprungen werden und Wechsel des
Pferdes gewissermaßen sehe ich im Moment
noch nicht das kann natürlich kommen
aber ich glaube es der Zwang jetzt auch
nicht als die moderne Koalition zu
scheitern nach Z Jahren das wäre ja auch
eine Katastrophe die sind ja angetreten
die wollten alles ganz neu machen
umwelttechnisch gesellschaftspolitisch
und jetzt zu scheitern da würde Scholz
als der oberverlierer da stehen das muss
man sich immer überlegen wie groß die
Kräfte also nicht nur fliegkräfte gibt's
ja es gibt ja auch Kräfte die schweißen
zusammen mhm ich kann mir auch
vorstellen dass das wieder mal so ein
externer Schock ist der dann die
Protagonisten notgedrungen
zusammenbringt und der vielleicht die
Kompromissbereitschaft auch auf allen
Seiten so ein bisschen erhöht und man
kann natürlich dann auch seinen Leuten
leichter erklären warum man Dingen
zustimmt die man vorher vielleicht noch
abgelehnt hat weil der
Handlungsspielraum einfach kleiner
geworden ist und ähm ich glaube das wird
passieren es wird weiter auch viel
gestritten werden aber tatsächlich ich
sehe nicht dass die Koalition zerbricht
das ist zu unattraktiv unter anderem für
Olaf Scholz selbst mhm und die FDP herr
Scholz FDP auch ja ja also wie gesagt
dieses politische Spiel wir werden es
sehen wie die Kräfte genau laufen wissen
wir nicht da selbst die Berater der
Politiker derzeit genau nicht wissen was
so in zwei Wochen ist also wenn sich das
dann wirklich entfaltet bislang hatten
wir so die alten Entscheidung die so
solide wir haben sie genannt R
renteeverteidigung und so weiter die
sind so im Kernhaushalt und wir glauben
die sind da irgendwie so sicher und am
Rand drumherum haben wir so diese
Klimapolitik gebaut und klar wir haben
auch einen großen generationabriss bei
der politischen Behandlung dieser Themen
nicht alle Altersklassen denken gleich
über dieses Verhältnis und diese
Relevanz dieser Themen und wir haben
zwei Parteien im Bundestag die die
Erstwähler für sich gewonnen haben die
Grünen und die FDP und vielleicht ist
das so eine neue Linie die wir jetzt
richtig in Ausprägung sehen wenn da
einfach Kämpfe geführt werden und wir
wissen wir kennen den Markenkern der FDP
sehen aber auch dass sie bei 4 oder 5%
steht die Grünen sind irgendwo anders
positioniert aber auch nicht mit großer
Reichweite in die Gesellschaft hinein
aber diese beiden Teilen jetzt diese
Themen unter sich auf und diese
Konflikte können wir glaube ich noch
nicht abschen danke mich find den Blick
auf die Jüngeren spannend weil das
Bundesverfassungsgericht sie haben es
angesprochen in der Tat zwei Linien
gezogen hat es hat vor einigen Jahren
gesagt ihr dürft keine Politik zu Lasten
der jüngeren machen Klimaschutz muss
schneller gehen als ihr das bisher macht
und jetzt haben sie entschieden dass ein
großer Topf aus dem das finanziert und
mitfinanziert
wird ausgekippt genau um um
Schuldenaufnahme zu begrenzen bedanke
mich sehr dieses Urteil hat Staub
aufgewirbelt ich hatte den Eindruck wir
haben so ein paar Staubflocken
weggeblasen aber so richtig klares Bild
haben wir noch nicht bedank mich für die
wenn sie dabei bleiben in der ARD das
europamagazin sonst im Netz im Radio und
bei phöniix Presseclub nachgefragt
tschüss lassen s gut
gehen und willkommen zurück presseub
nachgefragt im Fernsehen bei phöniix im
Netz und im Radio bei WDR5 und mit Jutta
Wirt in München guten Tag liebe Frau
Wirt willkommen im Presseclub hallo
guten Tag sie sind Dr können sie mich
hören ist es in Ordnung super sehr gut
wenn sie okay
ich habe zwei
Anmerkungen erstens finde ich es
vollkommen unangebracht die schwäbische
Hausfrau dauernd zu zitieren weil es ein
riesen Unterschied ist ob öffentlich
Schulden gemacht werden im Sinne von
Investitionen in Bildung Bekämpfung
Klimawandel und so weiter die
Notwendigkeiten sind ja allen klar oder
ob ich Privatschulden mache weil ich mir
neuen Fernseher kaufen will das ist die
eine Anmerkung und äh die zweite ist das
ist eher eine Frage Investitionen sind
kein verlorenes Geld sondern absolut
notwendige Ausgaben Schulden werden
ohnehin über Jahrzehnte gestreckt und
mindern sich durch die damit
einhergehende graduelle Geldentwertung
ein Vergleich mit der schwebischen
Hausfrau ist populär und unsinnig mhm ja
danke und und die Frage die darin steckt
war die Frage
geht
oder vielleicht an den her sch der sitzt
vorne links glaube ich von mir aus
gesehen ja gut jetzt hat Herr Müller
aber schon eingeatmet weil sie ein
Moment gezögert hat genau Herr Müller
ich habe das Bild nie verwendet bis Frau
Merkel unsere langjährige Kanzlerin ja
mit der schwebischen Hausfrau kam und
immerhin als Kanzlerin und auch als
regierungsverantwortlich eines wichtigen
Landes und ich finde das Bild insofern
der gar nicht falsch weil die
Verfassungswirklichkeit die oberste
verfassungsvorschrift ist der Haushalt
muss ausgeglichen sein wir reden jetzt
dar über Ausnahmen und Bremsen
grundsätzlich soll der Haushalt
ausgeglichen sein das scheint mir jetzt
nicht total pervers zu klingen auch
nicht so total anders als das was man
privat oder als Wirtschaftsunternehmen
anstrebt zumindest und Investitionen
müssen sein Notlagen erfordern neue
Schulden ist klar aber diesen Grundsatz
dürfen wir glaube ich nicht aus den
Augen verlieren und ich glaube das
meinte auch die Kanzlerin die ich auch
vielfach kritisiert habe aber das meinte
sie und das meint auch der
Finanzminister wenn er sagt wir müssen
alles eingenommen haben was wir ausgeben
können grundsätzlich Frau Wirt danke
dass Sie dabei sind das ist ein Strang
der Diskussion wir bleiben in München
harald Lesch ist in der Runde guten Tag
Herr Lesch und sie sind jemand der sich
auskennt grüße sie hallo gutag hallo
guten Tag ich habe eine frage direkt an
Herrn Müller sie haben es ja vorhin so
wunderbar als Chance bezeichnet hier
wäre ja viel möglich wie sieht's denn
aus mit den umweltschädlichen
Subventionen die uns Jahr für Jahr vom
Umweltbundesamt vorgerechnet werden das
ist ja die gleiche Größenordnung wie der
wie der Sonderfond der jetzt vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht für
verfassungswidrig erklärt wurde wäre das
nicht eine große Chance tatsächlich hier
Geld zu nehmen und es dann eben für die
für die Umwelt zu verwenden und nicht
der Umwelt damit zu schaden ja klar ich
habe ja gesagt alles auf dem Prüfstand
und Subvention erst recht muss man alles
alles nachdenken bin auch völlig
unideologisch ich nur gesagt man sollte
jetzt nicht klein klein anfangen sagen
was spannen wir da ein sondern ganz
grundsätzlich denken und da ja gehören
alle Subventionen auch dazu würde ich
sagen weil sie das eingebracht haben
haben sie ein Beispiel was da als
umweltschädliche Subvention z.B
gehandelt wird die Subvention des
Dieselpreises dass jeder Liter Diesel
mit 18 Cent subventioniert wird das ist
eine ziemliche Menge an Geld die kommt
und da könnte man z.B was überlegen auch
den Kerosin mit Mehrwert die Mehrwert zu
besteuern wäre eine Möglichkeit und
viele andere Dinge also ich kann nur
raten beim Bundesumweltamt in diesen
Katalog reinzuschauen das Bundeskabinett
hat hier praktisch direkt eine Blaupause
womit wie sie es machen könnte super
sehr gut danke Herr Lesch dass sie dabei
sind Gruß nach München und
ostbewern ist unsere nächste Station und
Bernhard löckner am Telefon hallo Herr
löckner einen wunderschönen guten Tag
jedes Kabinettsmitglied kann sich in
Berlin dem wissenschaftlichen Beirat
bedienen Frage ist die ideologische
Komponente vor allen dening bei den
Grünen so stark ausgeprägt dass man
diesen wissenschaftlich Beirat bei einer
so wichtigen entscheidenden
substanziellen Frage überhaupt nicht
heranzieht mhm das scheint ein bisschen
eine rhetorische Frage zu sein habe ich
den Eindruck so wie sie sie meinen ja
also ich kann die Frage für mich schon
beantworten aber ich hätte gerne eine
Antwort aus ihrer Runde heraus und wenn
ich das noch anmerken darf es wurde über
Klimapolitik gesprochen kann eine Person
ein Diskutant aus ihrer Runde mir
beweisen dass es den anthropogen
Treibhauseffekt gibt und dass für den
Klimaschutz so viele Milliarden
ausgegeben werden sollen nee das ist
nicht unsere Aufgabe wir sind
Journalisten und diese Beweise haben
andere angetreten aber Frau dankb zur
ersten Frage ja also
es hat ja der Kanzler vorhin gesagt alle
waren der Meinung dass es
verfassungskonform ist wie man das mit
dem Klima und transformationsfor gemacht
und in die Umwidmung stimmt natürlich
nicht denn es waren natürlich andere
Leute nicht der Meinung sonst geh hätte
ja auch keine Klage vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht gegeben und da
ähm das im äh Finanzministerium also die
Idee glaube ich kam vom ehemaligen
Finanzminister ausgearbeitet im
Finanzministerium und da ist natürlich
auch ein äh Wirtschafts und Jurist
wirtschaftspolitisch und juristischer
Sachverstand und ich nehme mal an dass
sie grünes Licht gegeben haben es ist
natürlich auch immer so bei solchen
Gutachten da glaubt man dem was man ähm
ja was man äh für opportun hält und was
einem sozusagen in die in was ein in die
Pläne passt das muss man natürlich auch
ehrlich fairerweise dazuag machen mal
weiter mit Günther Brez aus Ebelsbach
wenn ich das Stichwort hier richtig lese
denken sie über dieselbe Frage nach Herr
Britz wie konnte das sein ja hallo guten
Tag verstehen Sie mich ja sehr gut sind
dran ja schönen Gruß aus dem Frankenland
Gruß in die Runde ich habe eine kurze
Frage und zwar das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hatte dieses
Urteil gefällt es wird jetzt allgemein
über die politische und finanzielle
Aufarbeitung gesprochen aber was mich
interessieren würde äh findet auch eine
strafrechtliche Aufarbeitung statt weil
ich finde was hier begangen wurde ist
ein
ähm ja Subventionsbetrug mit einem
immensen Maß an Kriminalität begangen
von drei Parteien in Absprache und ich
finde sowas sollte auch strafrechtliche
Konsequenzen
haben also ich der Jurist also wenn wir
damit anfangen ich verstehe den Impetus
gewisserweise aber wenn wir damit
anfangen das wird in der Tat diskutiert
ministerhaftung Wissing Maut aber ich
glaube wenn man das zu weit treibt dann
werden wir nicht nur in der Lokalpolitik
wir werden kein mehr finden der in die
Politik geht das ist eine politische
Fehleinschätzung man kann auch sagen
wenn Experten sagen das ist
verfassungswidrig andere sagen es nicht
man versucht ich bin auch der Meinung
die erste Gewalt ist die erste Gewalt
also karlsruh ist nicht unsere Regierung
aber dass das jetzt dann eine Straftat
sein soll wenn die was
verfassungswiedriges beschlossen haben
wie sich dan nachh herausstellt wä mir
zu weitgehend mm wenn ich mir ein Kredit
aufnehme für ein Hausen Kauf Mitter von
Ferrari kann ich auch nicht sagen auch
ich habe man das jetzt anders überlegt
sondern will die Bank Geld zurück genau
aber das ist ja noch nicht per die
Straftat wenn sie dann nicht zahlen
können also das ist ja genau aber auch
da ist ja nicht alles strafbar und ist
auch gut so dass das Strafrecht das
letzte Mittel ist glaube ich Herr BRZ
danke dass Sie das eingebracht haben ich
glaube es geht um um
Gerechtigkeitsempfinden auch wenn die
Sache klar ist es ist kein Verstoß gegen
Strafrecht Gruß nach Franken schön dass
Sie dabei
sind gehen wir nach Rheinberg in
nordrehein-westfalen Margret Mertens
guten Tag Gruß an den rein guten Tag es
geht um die
statsschulden im laut Bundesbank
verfügten Privatleute im Juli über
7393 Milliarden Euro im Oktober waren es
schon 94 Milliarden
mehr es geht dabei nur um Bargeld
Wertpapiere Bankeinlagen und Ansprüche
aus Versicherungen ohne imob en Frage
könnte man nicht die Geld von
Millionären und Milliardären abschöpfen
bei ganz hohem
Selbstbehalt dann müsste die der der
dann müsste der Staat sehr viel Geld
haben dann wenn er das machen würde Frau
Mertens danke Frau
Rossbach die Vermögensbesteuerung
die ist ja aus den Gründen ausgesetzt
worden in Deutschland dass die Erhebung
relativ kompliziert ist kostet sehr viel
Geld überhaupt festzustellen wie viel
Vermögen hat jemand wie wird es bemessen
wo sind die Abgrenzungen zählt der äh
der der Dürer drruck im Flur mit oder
nicht deshalb wird die nicht erhoben
weil es sozusagen mehr kostet als es
bringt ähm ich finde man könnte über äh
Erbschaftssteuer nachdenken also dass
man da eine größere Egalität reinbringt
dass also der Satz niedrig ist aber den
alle zahlen müssen auch Unternehmen das
ist was was im Mittelstand sehr
unbeliebt ist
darüber könnte man nachdenken ich halt
eine
Vermögensbesteuerung ansonsten für zu
kompliziert und auch für für falsch und
nicht nicht nicht positiv erprobt hier
zu Lande aber eine andere Besteuerung
von großen Erbschaften gerade auch im
Bereich von von Unternehmensvermögen
könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen Frau
Märtens es ist im Detail kompliziert
aber auch das was sie fragen hat mit
Gerechtigkeitsempfinden zu tun deshalb
danke dass Sie diesen Aspekt noch mal
mit eingebracht
haben schweinfurt ist die nächste
Station genauer gesagt niederwern be
Schweinfurt hansjirgen Steinbach
willkommen im
Presseclub ja grüß Gott aus dem schönen
underterfranken ich wollte eine ganz
kurze Anmerkung machen vielleicht zu
diesem Thema Klima und diesem
V wir haben in Deutschland ein paar
Zahlen vielleicht vorwen wir verbrauchen
so 3900 tawatt Energie davon machen wir
etwa 10% nett mal
ökologisch erneuerbar Amerika vielleicht
noch zwei drei Zahlen hat 23 Billionen
Bruttosozialprodukt und 27 Billionen
Schulden wir haben irgendwo 3,8
Billionen und dann in Anführungsstrichen
nur 2,4 Billionen Schulden jetzt wenn
ich s die Leitung ist leider sehr
schlecht komm also tut mir leid
versuchen Sie gerne auf ihren Punkt zu
kommen wir können sie nicht sehr gut
verstehen ja ich probier es noch mal als
wir haben ein 80jährigen amerikanischen
Präsident der richtig viel Mut hat mit
einem Inflation Act bei den vielen
Schulden den die Amerikaner haben die
geben da richtig Gas die wollen da auch
scheinbar was erreichen wie gesagt ein
80jähriger Mann der da der da richtig
Mut und und und ESB hat und wir
diskutieren jetzt glaube ich eine
dreiviertel Stunde schon drüber ob wir
uns fenwell das Klima was kosten lassen
oder nicht es passiert einfach viel zu
wenig wir haben halt nur diese 350
terwatt im Moment erneuerbar 3900
verbrauchen wir und da gibt's für meine
Begriffe viel zu wenig Schwung und da
wollte ich mal dass ich vielleicht eine
Meinung dazu er ichtig seheil so richtig
vorwärts geht nich und jetzt diskutieren
wir uns zu Tode wie dieser 60 Milliarden
und ich sag mal die Amerikaner geben
zehn Mal so viel aus und haben deutlich
mehr Schulden wie wir und ich finde es
ist nur g leckere was wir da machen und
vielleicht haben sie eine Meinung dazu
danke Herr Steinbach so ich habe es
verstanden dass Herr Steinbach klotzen
möchte und deutlich mehr investieren MTE
also man kann ja auch hinter das Geld
was wir mit dem Geld eig gemacht es wird
etwas erwirkt die Amerikaner klotzen da
jetzt richtig rein wie er sagt
verschulden sich auch die machen ja
dieses Jahr mehr Schulden als
Deutschland insgesamt Schulden hat also
alleine in einem Haushalt und äh ziehen
aber auf unsere Kosten ihre Industrie
hoch was bedeutet in 10 15 Jahren wenn
der große Wettstreit um die
Schlüsseltechnologien ausgefochten ist
haben wir zwei Kontrahenten China und
Amerika die werden beide sehr hoch
verschuldet sein es wird sie aber nicht
interessieren nur in Deutschland haben
wir diese Schulden den Schuldenstand des
Staates als sehr prominentes
nachrichtenthema das ist in diesen
beiden Ländern nicht so whalb die sich
halt wirklich in eine vorteilhafte
Position bringen aber wir dürfen nicht
vergessen dass auch die Europäische
Union einen sehr großen Fond aufgelegt
hat mit dem Zukunftsinvestitionen
bezahlt werden und alles in allem lässt
sich das was da geplant ist in Europa
gemessen an Bevölkerung
Wirtschafts wirtschaftsgröße etc
durchaus vergleichen mit dem Inflation
reduction Act der USA okay wir lassens
stehen weil wir eigentlich keine
Diskussion zulassen bei nachgefragt
sondern ein Anruf und dann einer aus der
Runde Dank Herr Steinbach ein großes
Feld sie merken wir könnten die
restlichen Minuten darüber sprechen wir
sind jetzt in Aachen bei Alexander Kwas
guten Tag ja schöne Grüße aus Aachen wo
ich seit 1965 wohne und ich habe jetzt
hier mit Interesse die deutsche Politik
mit den verschiedenen Kanzler gefolgt
und dann das was ich jetzt erlebe das
habe ich ja in den über 50 Jahren also
nicht erlebt und ob jetzt hier die Ampel
hält dann möchte ich nur daran erinnern
was ein Minister vor 6 Jahren nach den
Wahlen gesagt hat es ist besser nicht zu
regieren als schlecht zu
regieren ja ich erinnere mich dunkel
dass dieser äh Politiker Christian
Lindner hieß ganz genau und ihre ja was
wollen Sie damit sagen ja ich wollte
sagen dass dieses Modell was sie jetzt
haben zum Misserfolg führen wird und
sollten vielleicht den Mut haben den der
Schröder gehabt hat der hat also vor
Ende der Legislaturperiode neue Wahlen
aufgerufen ich glaube das wäre die
sauberste Lösung jetzt mhm okay danke
Herr kavas ich sehe das Stichwort
Neuwahlen taucht auch in anderen Fragen
auf wer mag kann dazu was sagen gut wenn
das Parlament eine Vertrauensfrage
negativ beantwortet das hat ja Schmer
damals gemacht war eigentlich auch nicht
ganz verfassungskonform ist aber dann
gehalten worden und aber das was der
Eindruck auf den Bürger ist doch dann
auch es kommt eine unterhal aus
Karlsruhe okay 60 Milliarden ihr müsst
euch zusammenraufen wir machen
neuewahlen ich finde das auch so ein
bisschen
armselig ja Flucht in die Opposition
gibt es nicht es können nicht alle nur
Opposition machen ja ich würde sagen wir
gehen dann zum Schluss der Sendung nach
Bonn jetzt habe ich hier gerade den
Bildschirm ein bisschen verschoben so
jetzt kann ich bon drücken David von
Hase willkommen sie haben einen kurzen
Moment wir haben nämlich nicht mehr viel
Zeit ja schönen guten Tag in die Runde
ich hoffe man hört mich vielleicht ein
letztes Statement die CDU freut sich
aktuell über das Urteil stand jetzt
steht allerdings die nächste
Bundesregierung und somit schränkt sie
sich selber ein äh was die Zukunft
angeht wie wird also die CDU zukünfttig
mit dem Urteil angehen vor dem
Hintergrund dass sie sich aktuell
darüber freut danke Frau dankbar ja na
sie wird damit umgehen ich hatte es ja
vorhin schon gesagt
als Oppositionspartei kann man damit
anders umgehen als als Regierungspartei
da kann dann die Union so wie Herr
Müller sagte die Chance aus der Krise
nutzen und mal alles auf dem Prüfstand
stellen und eventuell eine ganz neue
neue zukunftsweisende Politik machen und
damit erstmal in den Wahlkampf ziehen
danke bei allen die angerufen
geschrieben gepostet haben das war eine
sehr lebhafte Debatte heute auch hier am
Tisch danke dafür ja wünsche Ihnen einen
schönen Sonntag aus Köln tschüss und
lassen
[Musik]
SK
ich denke wir
sind